like my brother's coming back around
like he's feeling that's Khloe
Kardashian teasing her brother Rob
Kardashian's return to keeping up
I just want Rob to do what's best for
him and what makes them happy and if
that makes them happy then we will all
support house the 36 year old reality
star opened up about her family's hit
reality show during an interview with
Sirius XM hits once the morning mashup
on Thursday we always say like when it
becomes unfun and we're all a dreading
doing something then hang it up I mean
it's not gonna last forever and we know
that and I think we're so okay with that
but like for Kourt if she wasn't feeling
that that was her happy place by all
means we don't want anyone to do that
of course khlo is referencing her sister
Courtney's recent decision to step back
from the show to focus on her three
kiddos with ex Scott Disick
I'm just decided to spend more time as a
mom and you know put more of my energy
there and still but I'm not saying
goodbye Kourt you might leave this week
she'll be back they all come back and
Chloe was right they always come back
case in point Rob like my brothers
coming back around like he's feeling so
I think he just you know started a whole
new season so you got oh the 33 year old
George Arthur designer took a step back
from the spotlight in 2017 after season
13 but his fan has kept ET up-to-date on
his status over the years he's doing
terrific Roberts good yeah he's working
out and eating good and so he's on a
good path right now Rob is doing great
he really is we love having him around
doing good yeah he's been really good
and in April Rob made a rare cameo on
the show to celebrate his daughter
dreams birthday try and blow all of
those out
get up now keeping up with the
kardashians is in the midst of its 18th
season and while some episodes have
already aired I know it's wild you see
us in like real-time of us experiencing
the pandemic and all the news and what
that means for an LA lockdown the famous
fam has had to shoot a lot of upcoming
episodes at home themselves due to the
coronavirus crisis it's a lot of us
filming but in our individual homes
either on tripods where you just set up
and go and it was very different and
awkward and we're so used to being in
each other's faces so it's different and
just like everyone else who is working
from home Chloe experienced some major
speed bumps along the way I thought I'd
push record once and I did and I'm
sitting there like having a whole
confessional to the camera and yeah
nothing happened it just kind of yeah
girl thanks oh my gosh I wasn't filming
wait anyway Chloe has been spending
quarantine with her ex Tristan Thompson
and their two-year-old daughter true now
I feel like I've kind of found my rhythm
this is my new normal and I am really
appreciating the reset button and all
the time that I do get to spend with her
Chloe opened up on the view about how
being a momma has changed her for the
better you put somebody else way before
your needs and I think it gives you a
different Drive in life that she's
definitely made me softer I definitely
have so much more empathy for my poor
mother and what she's gone through with
all of us and just it's a different kind
of love and until you have a child it's
really hard to experience and I've loved
my nieces and nephews like crazy but
there's nothing like having your own
[Music]